our immune system is necessary for
protection from the pathogens that cover
everything around us HIV or the human
immunodeficiency virus is a retro virus
that infects the important helper T
cells of the immune system helper
t-cells help activate B cells which
secrete antibodies that mark pathogens
and cytotoxic t-cells which destroy
labeled infected cells entry of the
virus into the cell is made possible by
receptors on the surface of t-cells
which interact with glycoprotein
complexes embedded in the viral emily
the viral envelope fuses with the cell
membrane and the virus deposits genetic
material and replication enzymes into
the host cell the genetic material of
the HIV retrovirus is RNA so let's be
converted to double-stranded
complementary DNA a reverse
transcriptase in order to be integrated
into the host cell's DNA by the enzyme
integrates integrase cleaves the
dinucleotide from each of the three
prime ends of the DNA allowing for the
viral DNA to be incorporated with the
helper t-cell escaping this DNA is then
transcribed and translated in order to
make building blocks for the new virus
with the helper T cells own metabolic
machinery after all the goal of the
virus is to make the target cell make
moral to virus the virus leaves the cell
matures and infect other cells the point
where there are not enough helper T
cells to maintain a healthy immune
system a lack of helper T cells weakens
immune function and makes patients more
susceptible to getting violent
from normally harmless packages combat
the virus is fatal activity highly
active antiretroviral therapy or part is
used includes combination of drugs that
suit inhibit HIV replication a positive
diagnosis for HIV is not a death
sentence because of the great progress
in time but the virus can't have fail
offensive